i made the decision to homeschool my
wife and i did because we had such a
great homeschooling experience ourselves
am i saying that homeschool families are
all engaged in abuse absolutely not
but i'm using that as an example of the
importance of having other adults other
professionals
have a sense of of what's happening in a
child's life outside of the home
homeschooling is not really about
maybe core religious beliefs again the
primary reason that most parents are
homeschooling is because of a school
safety or environment concern
for me
the claims that are made from that
community that it's more effective and
more efficient as a researcher i'm
interested in data and so for me i would
be interested in them putting that to
the test
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
i'm mikayla peterson
happy new year
guess who turned 30
this
girl 30.
anyway in this episode of opposing views
where i interviewed two experts with the
opposite opinion on social matters today
we covered homeschooling this is
important right now because the
schooling system is iffy right now i was
joined by dr t jamerson brewer and tj
schmidt
we spoke about home versus public
education curriculum decisions
educational qualifications the
socialization of homeschooled children
factors involved in abuse or academic
success ideology and teaching crt and
much more
dr brewer trains educators the best he
can for successful careers he's an
assistant professor of social
foundations of education at the
university of north georgia and received
his phd from the university of illinois
his scholarly work has been published in
many peer-reviewed journals including
education policy analysis archives and
educational studies my second guest is
tj schmidt who was home schooled
starting from second grade through high
school for much of that time his family
served as missionaries in haiti
he earned his juris doctor from oakbrook
college of law while serving as a legal
assistant at hslda where he's now a
staff attorney helping with legal
questions and challenges around
homeschooling
he definitely practices what he preaches
since tj and his wife homeschool their
seven children
if you enjoyed this episode be sure to
hit subscribe and happy new year again
tj schmidt welcome to my podcast
well thanks for having me
before we get started can you give a
brief introduction about who you are and
what it is you do
sure
well i'm one of the staff contact
attorneys here at the home school legal
defense association i've had the
privilege of working at hslda for almost
20 years
before that i was actually homeschooled
myself my parents homeschooled my
siblings and i in northern vermont
and
my wife and i currently are
homeschooling our seven children
i've been working as a staff contact
attorney at the homeschool legal defense
association as i said for almost 20
years and i have the privilege of
serving homeschooling families all
across the country currently in eight
states
so why did you choose to homeschool your
kids
well i think primarily for me i made the
decision to homeschool my wife and i did
because we had such a great
homeschooling experience ourselves
both of us were taught at home
my parents wanted to to start teaching
me almost really from the get-go but
because of the state laws at the time in
northern vermont they weren't able to
get approval until i was in the second
grade
and i was homeschooled from second grade
almost all the way up through high
school my wife was homeschooled from
first grade all the way through high
school
both of us had a really great experience
in homeschooling
of course
we did different things differently than
how we were taught at home you know we
had things that we liked things that we
didn't like but the overall experience
was something that we wanted to be able
to provide to our children as well and
provide them kind of that same
opportunity the flexibility uh just
really all the things i think when you
think about homeschooling
that when parents make that decision
that's what they're looking for to
provide to their children that's what we
wanted to do
what are the main arguments against
homeschooling
well i think some of the things that we
hear all the time um are that um
from parents would be well you know i
could never do that i could never uh you
know be with my children all day long
i'm not qualified to teach my children
you know i i wasn't good at math for
instance or you know i sucked at science
um
you know so so parents have concerns
whether they're capable of actually
educating their children at home
um i think obviously we're still dealing
with the whole socialization issue um
you know a lot of parents will say well
if you're homeschooled you're going to
be unsocialized you're not going to be
able to communicate with anyone else so
i think those are some of the the things
that we typically hear
but i would say all of those
very easily have been demonstrated in
the homeschooling community to be
honestly just false
in fact if you look at the information
out there more
homeschool students are
more involved in their community than
their public school counterparts
in socialization you know so that's that
really discounts that issue
when you talk about qualification you
know parents have the ability to
incorporate not only just their
own instruction that they provide to
their children but you know many
homeschool parents will use co-ops
they'll use uh maybe the private school
or even have their child when they get
into high school go to the local
community college
uh i've had both a son and a daughter
take like pre-calculus at local
community college my daughter's taking
some writing classes through the
community college so there's just no
limit to
you know who you can use and bring into
your homeschooling program and with
modern technology you can do online
classes from all around the world
and so there's really that i think
eliminates the concerns that some
parents have as well you know i couldn't
really teach that subject
and then as far as the you know kind of
the big one i couldn't be with my
children all day long um you know i
think
you know a lot of parents are concerned
about that but i can tell you you you
really develop a you know closer
relationship with your children and as a
family unit i think we've seen that you
know my older kids are you know much
more involved maybe in maybe their
younger siblings life than they would be
if they were in school six to eight
hours a day
and obviously we have time where we need
to be separated and
you know it's not always going to be
uh you know
roses but i think it does provide just a
wonderful opportunity to be more
involved and engaged as a family
together
yeah
strengthening relationships between
siblings isn't something i'd considered
for homeschooling so when you're doing
your specific version of homeschooling
do your kids learn together even with
the age gap
yeah so i have seven children and my
wife is a primary homeschool teacher uh
their ages range from 17 all the way
down to five so we have high school
senior to a kindergartener
and i think it varies it varies in
families it varies in our particular
family
there are a couple subjects that my wife
does teach in group setting so for
instance um
science
my kids are learning about
migratory birds and so
several of my children about four of
them are together learning about
migratory boards now
as their age range different you know my
wife may give one child a
more difficult assignment than maybe the
kindergarteners is just coloring a
picture of birds or like an arctic turn
so there are a lot of a lot of subjects
that can
work well in kind of a group study
and there's actually a whole group of
parents who will use like unit studies
and where they can teach
multiple grade levels i think of kind of
like a one-room schoolhouse
in in that kind of context
but then of course there are a lot of
subjects where depending on the level of
the student they're going to be working
more independently and coming to myself
or my wife for that individual
instruction like math or maybe english
things like that
do you guys do standardized testing
so
each state has requirements on what you
must do when you homeschool your child
there are a number of states about half
of them that do require some type of
standardized achievement testing
personally we live in a state where we
do have to test in the third fifth
eighth and tenth grades
and that would need to be submitted to
your local school district in our state
some states do require annual
assessments
personally my wife and i have just made
the decision to test our children every
year
um obviously we want our children to be
successful we want them to be productive
members of society we want them to be
able to go out and and
get a job or pursue anything that
they're interested in and so testing for
us helps us evaluate how they're doing
you know are they learning what we're
wanting them to learn
are there gaps where we maybe are
missing and i think even in states where
you're not required to do testing in my
experience a lot of parents feel the
same way they want to be able to know
hey
is all the effort that i'm putting into
this is it really working and you know
are we going to have children who are
going to be you know successful you know
they see how they're doing day to day
but they they want to be able to you
know maybe see how they compare
with
maybe other children of the same age or
grade level and so a lot of parents do
test even though there may be not be
legally required to do so are there any
states where homeschooling is illegal
so thankfully no there's no state there
where it's illegal back when hsld first
began in 1983 it was only clearly legal
in five states
and since that time really over the
early to late 80s
most states through the hard work of
you know committed brave homeschooling
parents who who you know took the stand
and said hey we want to be able to have
the opportunity to homeschool our
children
um and locals and state homeschool
organizations and of course hslda
working together we were able to get
laws passed uh or cases won in all 50
states so the last state
was in 1993
um and that would have been michigan
where you had to be a certified teacher
in nato in order to be able to
homeschool your child so that uh
drew case law was defeated back in 1993.
i didn't realize that this was recent
yeah well of course homeschooling has
been around really since the founding of
our nation i mean many of you know
families and children who came over as
immigrants and settlers early in the
founding of the americas were at least
in part taught at home
um and so you would have had
homeschooling really all throughout kind
of the colonial period here in the
united states but i think um
the early 19th century
you became more of a compulsory
education and so you know children were
attending public schools more and more
the modern homeschooling movement really
kind of took off in the late 70s early
80s and just
because of a variety of reasons
but
that's kind of where the modern
homeschooling movement kind of took off
interesting um how do you feel about the
argument that
parents aren't suited to be educators
because they haven't been
educated in education specifically
sure i mean that's a very common uh
concern i think that we hear a lot
um what i would say to that is well
first of all particularly in in this day
and age as i said earlier you you know a
parent
has the opportunity not only to use
their knowledge you know what they know
to be able to pass on to the children
but really the whole world is before
them and you don't have to rely solely
on what you know
and i think and most teachers will tell
you that the best way to learn is
actually to teach
i've known over the years in fact
one mom in particular that i remember
talking to she didn't graduate from high
school
but took on the challenge of
homeschooling her children her five kids
after they
went all the way through high school she
actually went back and got her master's
degree this is a woman who never
graduated from high school
but through the learning experience that
she had in educating her children
she
you know grew to have a love for
education
um and went on to get a higher degree of
education the thing that i would say is
that
you know i think the the number one most
important thing when homeschooling is
really that commitment or desire
homeschooling is not easy uh it's not
necessarily for everyone but i think
anyone can homeschool regardless of
their educational background and there's
a lot of research out there that has
actually looked at that specific
question
if you
have a high school education if you have
some college or if your post graduate
degree how is that going to impact your
child's learning in a homeschool
environment when you look at public
school statistics on this information
there's a huge gap you know you can you
can actually track how a student's
academic expected outcomes are based
upon the educational background of their
child in public school students and the
gap can range 30 to 40 percentile points
in standardized achievement tests when
you look at home school students that is
less than five percent
the gap between someone who has no high
school
you know hasn't completed high school
and someone who has maybe postgraduate
the really i think the key factor is
that parental involvement most of us are
homeschooling because we want our
children to be successful
we don't want our children to you know
not be able to get out and you know get
a job
uh you know i like to tell people that
you know i don't want uh you know my
child 40 years old living in the
basement i mean of course they'd be
welcome to live with us but you know i
want them to be able to go out and have
their own life i want them to be able to
be successful and pursue something that
they're interested in and so regardless
of our academic or educational
background when you make that commitment
to homeschooling if this is something
that you're desiring you're wanting your
child to be successful i think there's
plenty of opportunity
for you to be successful regardless of
what your personal knowledge in any
particular subject is
have you heard the argument that people
at home school
people homeschooling their children are
going to end up in some sort of echo
chamber along with other homeschoolers
yeah i think there are uh some people
who believe that uh you know
homeschooling is very insular um you
know i think the fact of the matter is
um
you know you're not when you're
homeschooling you're not in a log cabin
in the middle of the woods somewhere
there's very few people who are you know
that remote you know my parents uh began
homeschooling in northern vermont uh and
we we lived you know pretty far from the
road i took me almost an hour to get to
the to the school riding on the school
bus that was one of the reasons that my
parents made the decision to homeschool
us because
you know here i was spending two hours a
day almost just getting to school
and so we had much more of an
opportunity to homeschool but i you know
getting back to your question i would
say that
you know
homeschoolers have the opportunity to
expose their children to
all different points of of life all
different perspectives uh you know i
want my child you know not to be
um ill-prepared for
living
and i think if you look at the research
and the studies
homeschoolers are actually more involved
in their community than their public
school counterparts
on average homeschool students
participate in four to five activities
in a general week i mean i thinking in
my own children uh my wife and i were
actually talking about this the other
day uh
trying to get a date night in and uh you
know we have to plan around all the
activities that our children are doing
you know whether it's strings orchestra
practice whether they're participating
in a co-op program whether they're
involved in flag football or soccer or
all these other activities that they're
involved in engaged in they're exposed
to people and things constantly
and we also have the opportunity to talk
about current political events you know
sometimes i think my kids are too
involved in knowing you know what's
going on politically uh you know at
their young age but you know we
certainly have the opportunity to expose
and most homeschooling families that i
know
you know they're exposing their children
to all those things so again i think
it's a perception issue that most people
just think well this is what they think
of when they think of homeschooling log
cabin off in the middle of the woods you
know no electricity
okay
is it true that
people who homeschool on average make
more than people who aren't
homeschooling
well there is some research um on kind
of the income level but i would say on
average that's not true
the the statistics and information that
you see out there point that on average
most homeschooling families are a
one-income family
and so they're oftentimes making due
with less
than some of maybe their neighbors are
that's a sacrifice and a choice that
they've made
but
you know you've seen an increase or
we've seen an increase in homeschooling
just all across the board in fact
minority families are coming to
homeschooling at significantly higher
numbers
and it really makes no difference on
your socioeconomical background
on the
academic achievement of your child when
you're homeschooling it's the great
equalizer
and so i think that on average
homeschool families are
not as well off maybe as maybe their
neighbors again primarily because
they're making that sacrifice of
generally being a one-income family
okay
have you heard of the types of schools
where it's kind of combined where you do
some home schooling in some school
sure yeah so i mean there's a lot of
names for that i mean sometimes it's
called co-ops or hybrid homeschooling or
pod schooling or flex schooling you know
there's just a lot of different names
and i think it really speaks to the fact
that homeschooling you have a wide
range and flexibility in how your
educational model is
growing up my parents we were entirely
in the home
my mom was the primary teacher we didn't
participate in any co-ops
in my own
family now
we participate in a co-op one day a week
where the children are taking classes
with other homeschooling families
homeschooling moms or dads are the
primary instructor in that particular
class but like they're taking spanish or
physics or um
some other subjects that in a group
setting it's maybe
perhaps a little bit
more unique of an opportunity for the
kids to learn in a group setting and so
with co-op you can do that i've already
mentioned community college a lot of
high school students homeschool students
are going or taking community college
classes and really i think homeschooling
speaks to the flexibility that you have
to do that not every parent has the
ability to spend five days a week
homeschooling their children and so a
lot of pod schools have kind of sprung
up in covid where maybe one day they're
at
the smith's house another day at the
jones house another day that the
rodriguez family you know so there's
just a wide uh flexibility and most
state laws
require the parent to be the primary uh
person responsible for the education but
they don't necessarily require the
parent to be the only one who's
providing the instruction so you have
that flexibility and i think you know
because of covid we've certainly seen an
increase in more hybrid type
homeschooling programs but they've
always been out there
interesting
so how old do you have to be to attend a
community college course is that in
person or is that online
so um that really depends on your local
community college um
i've had you know
some states actually have dual
enrollment programs where homeschoolers
are entitled to participate for instance
like florida
with the community college and their
local school district they have an
articulation agreement that determines
the age of the student minimum age some
of them have a minimum age of 15 or 16.
our local community college does not
have a minimum age as long as you take
the placement test and you score a
minimum score then you can take any you
know dual enrollment class that you want
regardless of your age
i've helped kids get into college as
young as 12 11 years old so
there's really no limit on how
old you have to be it's it's highly
dependent upon the community college and
of course the student and their academic
ability
that's very interesting
i don't know much about canada's
system for homeschooling but i don't
think it's like that i don't think it's
as
do you know anything about it well so um
there is an hsld of canada and um so
they they have uh local chapters in all
the different provinces and uh we can
certainly connect you with hsld of
canada later but um i don't know off the
top of my head what
their options are as far as like dual
enrollment
maybe my parents were just lying to me
as a child no you have to go to school
homeschooling's illegal
anyway i i don't know
[Laughter]
um
who decides
okay so you said crew i think we covered
this already but curriculums decided by
the state
how how strict you have to be with that
when you're homeschooling
so i i would actually say that
curriculum is not determined by the
state um what what in the united states
uh the supreme court and a number of
even state constitutions prohibit the
state or the government from controlling
what curriculum content in private
education there's a number of really
important supreme court cases
dating all the way back to the 1920s
that have specifically said that no the
state cannot dictate to you
as a private education whether it's
private school or homeschooling what you
must teach now the the supreme court has
said that yes a state can mandate that a
child is educated that they are literate
that they are self-sufficient
but the state can't specifically say no
you've got to teach this textbook or
this curriculum
so most states what they require is that
you teach
subjects you have to teach math you have
to teach science social studies and so
forth
and they of course can require that
but
it is up to the parent in the
homeschooling program
what they are actually using to teach
that particular subject
now in some states you do have to
provide a list of the textbooks that
you're providing so for instance in new
york you have to provide an
individualized home instruction plan
form and in that you have to list the
textbooks or the curriculum materials
that you're using or your plan of
instruction
but the state the school district
doesn't have the ability to determine no
you can't use this textbook you can't
use that textbook they can only verify
that are you teaching subject are you
teaching math are you teaching science
so no state in the in the united states
can actually dictate what specific
curriculum
but they do dictate what curriculum is
taught in public schools
yeah absolutely when you're sending your
child to public school then
generally the state dictates the state
content standards that are required to
be taught
and then often on a local level the
school district is in charge of picking
particular textbooks
there are a number of states obviously
that have their recommended textbooks
for public schools but usually the local
control
at least in most extent is the school
district level the parent of course
has very little control over the
curriculum content of the public school
they could obviously run for school
board or they could voice their opinion
at the school board meetings but
ultimately that responsibility is either
from a state content state you know
standard requirement or the local school
district level on actual textbooks
is it expensive to home school
so generally uh most homeschooling
parents spend on average between three
to five hundred dollars per child
um and of course you could spend less or
you could spend more than that
i think for our family we spend with our
seven children we spend maybe two
thousand dollars total
uh to homeschool of our all of our
children now there's a lot of things
that you know we are uh purchasing every
year but there's some you know books
that we may purchase once and we can use
for uh most of our children or all of
our children so um there's there's a lot
of um you know a lot of parents will say
oh you know i couldn't afford to
homeschool my children you know i just i
can't you know i'm already paying taxes
i'm you know i've got other expenses
food of course you know gas right now
they just can't afford to homeschool
their children but i would say you can
homeschool regardless of your budget
there's a lot of free resources out
there that you can get
a lot of homeschool support groups
actually have lending libraries where
you can actually loan out a used
curriculum there's used curriculums
markets and sales that they have
even your local library
you know has a lot of resources and
information that you can use and
incorporate into your homeschooling
program
so
on average again three to five hundred
dollars but you can spend a lot less and
of course you know you could certainly
spend a lot more
okay
um
i i know that there's a good portion of
my audience that's being concerned about
public schools
specifically about ideologies being kind
of taught through them at the moment so
a lot of people are pulling their kids
out because they're saying i don't want
teachers teaching ideology to my little
kids so what what's your view on i guess
the dangers there and
is that avoided in homeschooling because
curriculum isn't as mandated
well you know so i think in a
homeschooling environment i mean again i
think most of us are homeschooling
because we're interested in our
children's education you know we want to
be invested in what they're learning
and as i said i think most of us are
also
you know trying to expose our children
to
everything that's out there but maybe in
a way that we feel is appropriate to
them based on their age or you know
appropriate to our family philosophy or
maybe our religious faith
and so i think all of those things are
key factors into reasons why parents you
know make the choice to homeschool
i think within the homeschooling
community you have a wide range of both
curriculum that you can choose from
there are some parents who use the same
textbooks that their public school uses
it's just that maybe their child's in a
bad environment the school environment's
not good they're getting bullied or
maybe they have a physical
you know handicap or mental handicap and
they're they're using the same
curriculum or textbooks and you have the
freedom and choice to do that in a
homeschooling program
but also because you have that
flexibility and freedom to choose other
curriculum you can use something that
aligns maybe with your philosophy your
religious beliefs um in a way that's
still providing the necessary required
instruction but is maybe dealing it on a
more sensitive level
um
we've seen a huge increase in uh
minority homeschooling in fact uh the us
pulse survey that came out just recently
of five times the amount of black
homeschooling families
it used to be about three percent of the
homeschooling population now it's over
16 percent of the homeschooling
population and one of the main reasons a
lot of black families are saying you
know what my child's not receiving a
good education or they're not being
treated in a way that i believe is is
you know
proper you know you know just a racial
tension within the school or they want
the flexibility to be able to provide a
more diverse curriculum to their
children they want their children to you
know not only just learn about uh black
history month but they want to be able
to provide
you know their children with a wider
range of and diverse
you know instruction that they couldn't
receive in the public schools
okay i think that sums up about
everything i want to talk about i guess
i could also cover
one of the concerns
that i've heard would be around religion
at home so what if people are bringing
their kids out of public schools and
then not teaching them things like
evolution
so do you have any views on that
well so if you look at the reasons that
parents are homeschooling their children
the number one reason is actually school
safety school environment
that's over a third of all parents are
actually that's their main reason
if if you look at it religious belief
is probably number four or five on the
primary reason so i think that that's
really
um
you know the the very few people that's
a fundamental reason that they're doing
it but i think again you have the
ability to provide your children with a
wide range of education and i think most
of the families that i know
they're providing their children with
all views just in the context of their
family in the context of maybe their
fundamental um
you know world view
uh but we have families who are
homeschooling from
muslim families uh you know christian
families secular families
you know atheists um
homeschooling is not really about
maybe core religious beliefs again the
primary reason that most parents are
homeschooling is because of a school
safety or environment concern
okay
was there anything else you want to
address actually before we stop um where
could people potentially go to find more
information on how to get this done or
how to bring their kids out of school
so the first thing i would say would be
they can go to ucanhomeschool.com
we have great resources on that website
if someone's considering homeschooling
they want to know what their state law
requires or how do they even begin
homeschooling they can go to you can
homeschool.com
and find out a lot information
here at hslda one of the key things that
we do is help educate parents on what
state law requires
help them get prepared we have
consultants we have special needs
consultants high school consultants we
can plug them in with a local support
group
i think when you're making that decision
to home school it's really important for
you to get plugged in with a local
homeschool group where
parents
you can talk with homeschooling parents
who've been there done that you can
compare notes on hey what curriculum
might work good for for my child
and i think it's it's just
there's a lot that goes into making a
good successful homeschooling program
and we do everything that we can to help
parents have that successful
homeschooling program
so go to ucanhomeschool.com
and you can find all the information you
may need there
okay so last question another concern
brought up is maybe some people some
kids are being kept at home because
they're in some sort of an abusive
environment
and so homeschooling is a cover for that
how do you feel about that argument
well again i i would say that as a
parent my primary concern is my children
and their well-being i want them to be
successful i want them to have a good
academic foundation i want them to be
able to go out and do everything that
they can and i would say
99 of all parents who are homeschooling
their children that is their primary
concern and you know who can be better
concerned for their children than the
parent
and so i think any
view of child abuse or neglect is
reprehensible to me and i think to the
vast majority of homeschooling parents
no one wants to see a child abused and
we're doing what we're doing because we
love our children we want them to be
successful
i think unfortunately there is child
abuse whether it's in a public school
private school or homeschooling and i
certainly think that the government
responsibility is to you know find and
catch those situations
i don't think that there's any there's
no research out there that says that
homeschooling is is more
dangerous
for child abuse in fact if you look at
child abuse statistics statistically it
is more
frequently occurs in a public school
environment not only are others uh
involving in child abuse
maybe in the home but also in teachers
and then
over 20 percent of all students public
school students say that they've faced
unwanted abuse from peers in the public
school environment and again i think
that speaks to the again the primary
reason that parents begin homeschooling
is because the safety concerns whether
it's bullying
abuse
just just context in fact i just spoke
with a mom just two weeks ago her
eight-year-old son was coming home
crying because he was being assaulted
and bullied at the school he had bruises
over his body you know mom talked with
the public school and said hey you know
this is going on this needs to stop and
she just grew frustrated they didn't do
anything they couldn't control this
issue and she she took it upon herself
to homeschool her son because she
couldn't see
him abused anymore in that system
okay thank you very much for coming on
if people want to find you is there a
place they should go other than the
website you mentioned
yeah so they can also find us uh give us
a call at
540-338-5600 or they can visit us online
at www.hslda.org
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
let's be honest everyone needs help at
some point in their lives some more than
others reasons may vary wildly but that
doesn't change the fact that no matter
where you are in the world better help
is available and ready to lend a hand
better help matches you with a
professional therapist in under 48 hours
you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your therapist
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions ahead of time
it's easy to see why over 2 million
people use better help it removes all
the potential hassle and awkwardness and
gives you the same end product in a few
simple steps
their licensed professionals are
categorized by specialty on the website
making it even easier to match with one
if for whatever reason you're not
satisfied it's also super easy to try a
new one betterhelp wants you to start
living a happier life today visit their
website and read their testimonials
better help is also more affordable than
traditional offline therapy and
financial aid is available for those who
need it they have a special offer from
my listeners you can get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
peterson and join over 2 million people
who've taken charge of their mental
health with the help of experienced
professionals in fact so many people
have been using it this service that
additional therapists are being
recruited in all 50 states that's better
help as in hglp.com
peterson or just use promo code peterson
for 10 off hope you enjoy the rest of
the episode
dr jamison brewer welcome to the podcast
thank you for having me
so before we get started would you mind
giving a brief background about who you
are and what you do
sure so currently i am an assistant
professor of social foundations of
education at the university of north
georgia and what that means is i teach
courses to pre-service undergraduate
[Music]
teaching candidates so these are folks
who are trained to become teachers in
the k-12 world
i myself having once served as a k-12
teacher i taught 7th 9th 10th 11th and
12th grade history and social studies
yikes how was that
it was unique um seventh grade is uh
scary um they're going through a lot of
changes and and it's um unique is the
best word i can give to that
but high school uh was certainly much
more comfortable for me um i enjoyed
that
okay so i brought you on to talk about
homeschooling in particular because from
what i've read more and more parents are
pulling their kids out and homeschooling
so i have a bunch of questions to throw
at you but to begin
what's your overall view on that but
homeschooling in particular
sure so broadly conceptualize my
research and academic and scholarly work
is situated in the question of
privatization of k-12 and and then takes
on a lot of different forms uh school
vouchers uh charter schools uh but
homeschooling right so
homeschooling is um the sort of
quintessential um iteration of school
choice um and it's also uh one of the
oldest forms of schooling in general um
since the beginning of man
parents have been teaching their
children at home uh how to survive uh
and and various other things
uh for me
when i think about this question of my
view of homeschooling
it comes back to of course my
my own experience
as a k-12 teacher as someone who
currently trains future teachers as a
parent myself
my spouse is also a k-12 teacher
uh it comes down to a question of
what do we consider to be the importance
of education uh and to whom should we
leave that too
um you know so there are lots of
questions and i'm sure we'll get into it
in our conversation about parental
sovereignty
but there's also some questions that
should be raised about what it means to
be a professional educator
and is this process of education or
schooling
is it something that as a society
uh we conceptualize as something that
ought to be overseen uh and delivered uh
by professionally trained individuals or
is it something that is either
not that important or
is the process of teaching and child
development
not a science not a profession
that could be done by by anyone and in
this case a parent
so what do you think about that
it's a great question um
i will i'll give you two answers to that
uh as i said uh i'm i'm a former teacher
i train teachers now my wife is a
teacher and we have two children ages
seven and six uh both of our children
attend public school i think that
uh you can imagine that we might be
qualified to teach our children at home
but having the qualifications and
experience that we have in education uh
we know full well that we are not
qualified to provide a holistic
and purposeful education to them across
the myriad of subjects that students
learn in schools
across the myriad ways that schools
allow students to socialize so for me
and sort of um making actionable my view
on homeschooling
as a parent i have the option to
homeschool and i have specifically
chosen not to homeschool because i don't
believe it to be the best way at least
for me
uh in in our family to to go about the
education of our children
uh
to the question of whether others should
or should not obviously that's a
question for them to answer
but again it raises the question for me
um
of
this idea of whether uh teaching is
something that anyone can do and that
you need that and if you're
homeschooling you need not be trained
and how to do that in pedagogy and child
development lesson planning and the
specific subject area knowledge
uh and when i
start down that road of questions um i
find less and less convincing arguments
that would support homeschooling
okay um the origin of schools with like
the size they are in the classroom size
were they not designed
um to kind of create factory workers to
get people into that mindset
so the short answer is yes
a more complex answer is that not all
schools have been that way you know
certainly schools that that tend to more
affluent families more affluent areas
have long issued those sorts of
approaches to education right and that's
a conversation to be had but you're
right for the masses
schools were designed to train students
to work in factories we have ringing
bells schedules and things like that
and so and and to be clear from the very
outset of this conversation
my critique of homeschooling or school
vouchers or charter schools or things
like that uh should not be understood as
a an across-the-board endorsement uh for
how we've done education i think that
there are room for uh reforms and
improvement within the public school
space so it's it's not a all of this or
or nothing
um
but yeah that's what schools were
designed for certainly we don't operate
really in that type of economy anymore
and so it needs to be updated it needs
to change
and it has
very slowly but again
in more affluent areas this is not
something they've dealt with the schools
were designed for a different purpose
and they've served that that
community well over time
given the kind of influx of people
bringing their kids home and
homeschooling them do you think there
should be government guidelines stopping
people from doing that or encouraging
them to go to school more than they
already are
yeah so
um
in almost every state it's it's
exceedingly easy
to opt into homeschooling whether that
is simply filing a letter to of intent
and in some cases really almost nothing
the question of government oversight
regulation right if if that's what we
want to call it
um is something to be discussed and for
a couple of reasons
um as i'm sure we may discuss claims of
effectiveness whether homeschooling does
better or not um so much of what we know
uh about the homeschooling community is
from self-reporting uh and and that's
sort of by design right i mean these are
communities that have made a conscious
decision to withdraw from sort of the
public's face in this area and some type
of government oversight you know from
the local school
so we really don't know much about
what's happening other than what's being
reported
um we do know
a few things that um
when covet happened and schools shut
down or are moved to fully digital
um there was a 50 reduction uh in
reporting um
suspected cases of abuse and neglect to
the authorities that usually happens as
a result of schools
am i saying that homeschool families are
all engaged in abuse absolutely not
but i'm using that as an example of the
importance of having other adults other
professionals
have a sense of of what's happening in a
child's life outside of the home
uh and so
if we operate on the assumption that
homeschooling will continue to operate
and maybe even grow
for me
the claims that are made from that
community that it's more effective and
more efficient as a researcher i'm
interested in data
and so for me i would be interested in
them putting that to the test
i do think that there should be some
whether it's a counselor a educator
somebody with some professional training
and background
to have once a year twice a year i'm not
exactly sure what that looks like
but some sense of what is being taught
uh how it's being taught uh whether the
children are being taken care of or not
and you know to be honest a significant
portion of the answer is going to be yes
that things are great and the children
are well taken care of
but obviously in some cases that might
not be the case and i do think that as a
society we
we've clearly
collectively made the decision that all
of us as adults and myself as an
educator i'm a mandated reporter
that that we have an obligation to look
after uh children uh who cannot speak up
for themselves uh and so yes i do think
that there should be some intervention
uh regulation oversight you can pick the
word that you like um but but currently
the way that it's operating on
also cannot be sustained
okay so
let's start with this what have you seen
from your research um about the efficacy
of homeschooling versus public education
yeah so uh those are generally so we
have rationales for homeschooling and
those generally not always but they
generally uh fall into religious
category or political or
curriculum-based category
but the sort of justification on the
back end uh is that is more uh efficient
uh and it's more effective and by
effective i mean that it produces better
academic outcomes and
um again returning uh that's troubled a
bit by the fact that the data that we
have from homeschooling families is
self-reported
uh and so from the beginning it's a it's
a little bit problematic um because
there's not a lot of incentive for
homeschooling families
that are struggling and and academics
are not going so well to report that to
anybody uh and so it's likely that some
of the data is a little bit biased
towards the positive
but even with that
uh we know we have the the benefit of
knowing that many home school students
are not home school k through 12
exclusively that they may start home
school in the early childhood grades and
then transition into public school
middle or high school
usually as a result of the parent
recognizing uh their sort of lack of
more advanced content subject knowledge
uh or going in and out and it could be
based on uh the family moving around
maybe a military family whatever that
might be but we know that
families excuse me that students who are
homeschooled generally and again it is
self-reported data but generally they do
better
than their peers in public school
but we know that they do better whether
they are in homeschooling or in the
public school
and so from a research standpoint what
that tells me
is that it's not necessarily the
treatment it's not the the mechanism of
schooling that they're receiving
but it tells me a little bit more about
the sort of background that the child is
coming from
homeschool families roughly speaking
make as a household income
somewhere between twice or three times
as much as the typical or median
household income in in the united states
and we've known since the 50s we've
known since the 50s that
how much money parents make has a direct
impact on the academic outcomes of their
children for lots of reasons they can
afford books they can afford trips and
to museums and things like that
um and so the fact that they do well and
by they i mean the homeschooled students
do well whether they are being
homeschooled or in the public school
tells us that it's perhaps not a result
of the homeschooling and more so a
reflection of the economic realities of
that family
why would people who earn two to three
times as much decide to pull their kids
out of public school to home school
well from the the very easy answers that
they can afford to right um to the to
the question about um
efficiency and the cost associated uh
with homeschooling
uh it's it's generally uh
you will see organizations say you know
it costs you know six or seven hundred
dollars a year to homeschool your child
at home and they're usually reporting
the cost of buying some books and some
sort of curriculum subscription
but they're leaving out the reality that
it does require generally speaking the
opportunity cost of one parent giving up
a salary
and so for a lot of families and again
not all but for a lot of families who
homeschool
that do operate from a one income
household that one income is exceedingly
higher than the median single income
across the country
and so they do it simply because they
can they can afford to do that uh and
and but it does generally come down to
uh
the the typical rationales of religious
rationale or some type of political or
academic rationale
how do you feel um
okay one of the arguments put forth by
people who are pro homeschool i would
say is
or or ansi home school perhaps is that
socialization is an issue if you're
homeschooled so what are your views
about socialization in regards to
homeschooling
yeah so the sort of stereotype for for
generations has been that you know
homeschool students are not socialized
and that becomes a problem for them when
they move into adulthood or when they
come to university
um you know in some time in some cases
that that might be true uh me personally
i think that it tends to be an overblown
stereotype because exceedingly um even
within homeschooling communities
i think that they recognize and maybe
it's not just to fight off the stigma
of their children not being socialized
but in recognizing the need to socialize
a lot of home swimming communities have
developed networks for their children to
engage with one another throughout the
day throughout the week whatever that
might be
i certainly think that that's better
than not having socialization and and i
don't imagine anybody would disagree
uh for me though i think that the
broader question would become back to
that question of what is the purpose of
education in schooling
and if we can agree that we're no longer
interested in training students for work
in factories but that education does
still serve a larger purpose to prepare
children to enter into adulthood and
enter into our society
it does raise some significant questions
for me
for a homeschool family
that is engaging in some type of social
activities with their children
with other homeschool families and not
just by the nature of the homeschool but
it's far more likely that they're
operating within a sort of echo chamber
a bubble whether it's an ideological
bubble whatever that might be
and and whether that's um an audio an
ideology a political one to the left to
the right or religious ideology i i
think most of us can understand that
that's not how society works uh and
and if we understand schooling and
education to be preparing children for
that
it becomes problematic for me to for
anyone to suggest that socialization
within an echo chamber or an ideological
bubble
is beneficial
to the contrary public schools um by
their very nature tend to be more
diverse from viewpoints and backgrounds
and religion and whatever that might be
and for me
it represents a
greater opportunity or more aligned
opportunity for children to become
socialized into
what society will be for them as an
adult
than sort of
recoiling away from that into our our
little corners whatever those corners
might be
okay i would say
just from speaking to a few people
who've been homeschooling their kids
that part of the reason they pulled
their kids out was because they felt the
public schools were becoming the
ideological echo chamber
so how yeah
yeah so that that and of course anybody
paying attention to the news in the past
you know six to ten months that it's a
conversation the the virginia governor's
race was not single uh
issue decided on this but what played a
significant um
factor in the outcome
the problem is
well i'll say this
uh for public school to engage in
curriculum
with few exceptions that is generally
overseen by a school board which is
democratically elected uh and so uh
parents and whether their parents or
just local
tax paying citizens have a voice have a
say-so in the process the curriculum the
design of their local school
by its very nature
being
being disappointed being disgruntled or
being misinformed about what curriculum
might be or what
what it might not be
is a problem right and social media has
certainly exacerbated a lot of these
things
uh but to give you an example right um
you know the current example is is crt
but
but yeah but a sort of historical
example
and specifically within the homeschool
community
might be something uh like evolution
right uh this idea that that evolution
is being taught in the local public
schools uh and a lot of families will
opt to home school uh because for for um
ideological or religious reasons uh they
don't see an alignment uh with their
child being exposed uh to the theory of
evolution
uh so it's not a new idea it's not a new
concept that parents have taken issue uh
with the curriculum at the local school
or that they've opted to homeschool
because of that
but again for me and with with the
example of evolution
uh i would take it back to the question
of what's the purpose of schooling and
education um you know having a child
learn about the theory of evolution
is not by its design intended to
force a student
or encourage a student to throw off
their cultural religious identity uh
it's a theory and it's it has been
adopted in science
and through that process in in the
preparation for children to enter into
society as an adult
we may collectively agree
that having that shared sense of
knowledge is something that's important
whether or not they go into you know
work as a biologist or whatever that
might be
but it does become problematic um and i
say this is apparent as well
if i conceptualize the local public
school curriculum
as something that i could or should be
able to sort of a la carte pick what i
like what i don't like
because again that that raises the the
specter that i
am more of a content expert more of a
pedagogical expert
than
the the educators in the local school or
the broader school district
would the example of evolution be
compared to uh
the current teachings in crt
i think that
i think that parents
fears um founded or unfounded about crt
about evolution about sex ed
which historically is also a sort of a
topic that encourages a lot of families
to homeschool
again
it comes to the question of should
education be uh sort of pick and choose
a la carte uh what i want my child to
learn and what i don't want them to
learn
um
but also in understanding that
if i homeschool if i choose to do that
that isn't all one thing and none of the
other right so if i pull my children out
of public school it is none of the
public school and all home school
having children be in the public school
space
by comparison does not preclude parents
from sharing their own world view their
own ideological or religious world views
with their children and so for me being
in the public space represents the
opportunity of a this and that as
opposed to this or that
and again i think that a lot of it comes
down to fear
uncertainty about what a particular
subject in the curriculum might mean
for a student what the rationale or
motivation for that topic to be in the
curriculum might be
but those are questions that the parents
could ask and should ask
and for me i would encourage them to ask
those questions and and be in a
conversation with their school board
with their local school uh teachers and
leaders uh as opposed to
the sort of withdrawal uh from that
system and that process um into their
own echo chamber where
it might be more comfortable maybe for
the parent but again it comes back to
raising some significant questions of
what that might mean
for the child when they become an adult
themselves
do you think it's possible that people
earning two to three times the average
income actually do know how to teach
their kids better than the public system
that's a good question uh so i'll just
use myself as an example again
um you know i i probably make more than
than the typical individual i'm not
talking about a household income
but it comes down to this question of
what does it mean to be a professional
educator
and i i think that
the problem in the united states um
is that because all of us have gone
through education uh most of us fancy
ourselves as experts in education uh and
i i tell folks if you don't believe that
next time you're checking out at the
grocery store ask the either the person
in front of you or behind you
if there are problems in education and
how to fix them and they definitely have
answers
for both of those questions
so
for the logic to hold true
at least in my view it would have to
hold true in another context you know
this past year my daughter
who was riding her bike and and fell off
uh and skinned her knee um yeah a minor
small abrasion
and
this is not a function of of my income
um but i felt
um competent enough uh to know uh to not
use hydrogen peroxide to use rubbing
alcohol and clean it and apply bandage
uh and and it generally was fine and she
healed just well um but comparatively
if my daughter had fallen off of her
bike um and and broken her leg uh say
broken her femur compound fracture the
bonus through the skin
um would i in the same situation given
the same background training the same
income would i feel competent and
qualified enough to tend to her injuries
and the answer i think for any of you
viewers would be obviously not uh and
and we also know that if i uh did
pretend or fancy myself as qualified to
do that i may come under trouble uh for
neglect uh for my child if i don't seek
medical attention for her in that
particular instance
so
is somebody who makes enough money
qualified um
i don't know that that's the the i don't
know that a good answer to that question
should follow in the sense of
uh if it's not true across any other
area of child development it's probably
and likely not true here in education
just having money
does not make one an expert in how to
deliver
content how to engage in pedagogy or
understand
child development in such a way
that lessons are age-appropriate and not
just in the content sense but
even how the the childhood
child brain understands hypothetical
questions or it doesn't
these are things that professional
educators learn in their training and
through experience
and at least in my view makes them
exceedingly more qualified
to deliver education to children
probably doesn't teach things like crt
either
you're at home
i mean if you make more money it doesn't
mean that you know about that either
no yeah absolutely um you know i myself
i have a doctorate in education policy
uh i never once had a class in crt all
the way through graduate school uh and
so i i i mean i i have a general
understanding what it is but i i am no
beans an expert in crt
um
where did you get your education sure i
did my bachelor's degree at valdosta
state university
and that was my initial training
to be a
middle to high school history teacher i
did my master's at georgia state
university and my phd at the university
of illinois in urbana-champaign
and was what year was that if you don't
mind me asking of course i graduated
with my phd in
2016
my master's in 2012 and my bachelor's in
2007.
okay are you saying so you said what you
do now is basically educate people on
how to educate people
that's right so my students are
most of them are sophomores and as an
undergrad student
who are taking a sequence of courses
prior to applying for entry into
the college of education of course that
would be a subset of the university
itself
um and so i teach courses on critical
and contemporary issues in education
educational psychology
and things of that nature
okay and you said you haven't come
across crt or that's not being taught
very much from what you've seen
yeah throughout my entire coursework
i did not take a course on crt and and
that's certainly not anything that we
teach
current
training teachers as best as i
understand the the formal groundings of
crt it's a
um something taught in in law schools
that stemmed um from the early 90s i
don't know exactly when the theory sort
of picked um
became a thing but certainly in the
early 90s
okay do you think um
do you think some of these problems
potential problems with homeschooling
could be ameliorated with just
compulsory
testing every so often
um
maybe um but that that raises some
questions about the the benefit of
testing in general right um
doing more excuse me
doing more testing
for the sake of testing whether it's in
public school or homeschooling is
is generally not good education it's not
good pedagogy and teaching right it sort
of creates the environment in which you
get teaching to the test and and to some
extent that that has existed in public
schools right so again i'll remind you
reviewers that i'm i'm not giving an
across-the-board uh non-critical
endorsement of public schooling either
um
i think that it could be part of it we
do know that a lot of homeschool
students will take the sat
for example and usually for entry into a
university um it can make it easier
for
the application process for a student
who's been homeschooled to enter into
university if they have a more
standardized point of reference
but we also know that
sat scores are highly correlated with
family income as well right so
uh we do know that homeschool families
our
students do generally
do better on the sat when they take it
than their public school counterparts
but again that's
for me that's more of a reflection of
their sort of home economic background
that it is the the type of education
that they have received
um
i i think that
having check-ins and again i i have i
don't know and i don't pretend to know
you know what frequency that might be
if homeschooling would continue
for academic considerations for the
general well-being of the child those
considerations as well
those would be important
policy conversations to have
but again of course
the the easier solution as it were
would be to encourage attendance at
public schools as opposed to creating
new mechanisms
of oversight for a process that that may
or may not
have a real rationale for existing
and so how would you encourage uh more
attendance to public schools
i think it's conversations um with with
families you know generally
if you ask
most americans at least in my case um
you know
tell us your sense of
how public schools are doing
if you ask them to grade their local
school and this is true whether they
have a child in that school or not
they generally will give the local
schools that they live around an a or an
a minus but generally a favorable um
grade towards the local schools
but then if you ask them about the
schools over there right across the
district across the state across the
country
they will rank them as a c all the way
down to an f
and so what that tells us is that
collectively as a society we've really
bought into this idea this notion that
schools public schools have failed and
and they're bad
um
but when you ask local folks tell us
about your your local school
they they like them right uh and so
that's a more meaningful and telling
artifact of the actual state and nature
of schools is that folks who are engaged
in understanding uh of the local school
again whether they have a child there or
not tend to be very favorable uh towards
that school
um i think that the media has certainly
played a role in in hyping up you know
the sort of myth of the failed school
and that rein that informs how we feel
about other schools
um but it's hard to feel that way when
we're able to see uh the school it's
easier for me to develop a negative view
of of how schools might be in say
nebraska
because i don't live there
and so i can just get on social media or
the media in general and hear that
schools have failed
and just take that at face value i think
that we need to have conversations about
the realities of schools the benefits of
public schools
um the downfalls that that need to be
attended to and fixed um but
collectively fix that together as
opposed to um
pulling away from that that possibility
because public schools do represent
the
the best opportunity that we have
to provide all children with an equal
opportunity we know currently that they
do not we know that schools that serve
dominantly white students uh receive 23
billion dollars a year in additional
funds than schools that don't
that's a problem that's a conversation
to have so they're not living up fully
to the um
possibility of providing an equal
opportunity um but going in the exact
opposite direction
um certainly won't get us any closer uh
to public schools realizing that
potential
okay okay let me see what else do i have
here
okay
um
do you are you aware of how curriculum
is decided for schools
yeah so generally speaking um that is a
decision um by either a
statewide governing agency
a board of regents or
state superintendent
different states have different uh
phrasings and words for that
local school districts
have some autonomy in that that decision
and that process as well
and then down to the local teacher um
the teachers are prescribed a a very
specific set of standards
uh that must be taught um it does i can
say as a former history teacher it does
generally feel
overwhelming to try to teach so many
standards in so little time
um especially with with the increase in
and preparing students for uh
standardized tests
that may or may not even be connected to
that content
um but as a local teacher you have some
uh leeway and and
not necessarily what's top but how it's
taught right we understand that teachers
are the experts and and the
professionals in the classroom
but there's a system in place from the
teacher to the local school board to the
state apparatus
that makes those decisions and the
benefit of public schools
is that at every level
there's public input right whether that
is
in deciding who is the state
superintendent through an election
um or
even if that's an appointed position say
by governor uh
people having say so and who that
governor might be
to the local district and even to the
local school with with the principal and
the teachers at every point there's an
opportunity for public input in public
oversight as it should be
whereas
other types of school delivery whether
it be private schools or or the epitome
of it in homeschooling
there's little to no public oversight
into what curriculum is taught how it's
selected and how it's delivered
uh you mentioned private schools there
for a second so is there
a major difference between public
schools and private schools in regards
to what they're being taught
yeah and and just speaking on that note
um
public schools um have full autonomy in
their curriculum uh in their admissions
uh process uh a a publix or excuse me a
private school that is religious in
nature uh can have a litmus test on a
prospective student uh fitting within a
very specific
understanding of a religious
denomination um or
to whether they're accepted or not
certainly that's not allowed in the
public school space
but to the curriculum space as well
private schools represent an autonomous
body that make decisions about student
entry student discipline hiring firing
and curriculum all on their own with
zero
outside or public oversight
interesting okay
okay well i think that covers
what i wanted to ask you about
homeschooling is there anything else you
wanted to mention while you're here
yeah thanks for that opportunity again i
would i would conclude as it were um
reiterating this this question or this
notion of
how do we as a society conceptualize
education and the importance of it uh
and if it is something that we
conceptualize and understand to be of
vital importance
for children for their development and
their lived realities both as a child
but also in preparation for adulthood
is that something that warrants
a space
where where they go uh to engage in that
process with trained professionals
or is that something that that anybody
can do and in the case of homeschooling
that their parents can do
um
is having a high school diploma
good as it is is that sufficient
for teaching children um not just
kindergarten but all the way through
advanced trigonometry as a high schooler
those are some important questions to
ask
again as a society
we we generally would not condone
parents choosing or electing
to provide medical care for their
children
or firefighting care for their house
right sort of pulling away asking for
their tax money back from the local fire
department um those are not things that
as a society we would really
um
allow or or be okay with uh and so when
it comes to education the fact that we
are readily okay with that for children
should raise some concern um but again
it gives us the opportunity as a society
to think through uh what does it mean to
educate a child uh and if that is an
important process should we and at least
in my view we should um
rely on trained educated professionals
to do that with the opportunity for
parents to be engaged in that process uh
whether that's through the political
process of
speaking at local school boards or
running for a local school board or just
in conversation with their teachers
it does take a village to raise a child
we need to understand that
and it seems to me that public schools
represent the better opportunity to
engage in that process
uh than than a child being kept at home
okay
thank you very much for coming on if if
people want to find you online where can
they go
yeah i have a website it's t
jamesonbrewer.com um and my twitter
handle is the same it's at t jamison
brewer and uh through there you can
connect with me in myriad ways
okay thank you very much
let me say michaela uh i appreciate the
invite i appreciate the
the conversation and the questions that
you had and and giving me the
opportunity to to be long-winded on some
of them um no apologies to them at all
no no no that was good
[Music]
you